so the best part about sitting down to
do a podcast with you is that you are
never on the receiving end of these
things
and you have made quite a career out of
getting people to say all the things
they don't want to say
and now here you are on the receiving
end yeah it's terrifying now you know
how we feel
I'm not going to start with he was
here's how nice I am I'm not going to
start with I'm going to ask you a
question most people lie about the
answer and I want you to be honest how
are you I'm not gonna start that but how
are you and how am I I'm good
interesting chapter of my life it's an
interesting chapter of my life I think
um
things feel more balanced than ever if
that makes sense when I say balanced I
don't mean in any equal proportion I
just means quantities that make me feel
good right and I feel like I'm in a bit
of a boring phase of my life and in an
interesting way to find boring just this
kind of straight compounding phase of my
life where nothing huge happens but in
fact everything is happening because
it's boring it's the same it's showing
up every day it's discipline it's boring
mean routine or does boring mean you're
bored it means
um there's not a huge variance in the
amount of experiences but it's
intentional so it's maintenance yeah
Focus
focused
that is counter to your personality and
what I mean by that is
you know you're you are sort of an
entrepreneurs entrepreneur you you know
dropped out of school went into business
by yourself sort of live the
entrepreneurial life and entrepreneurs
their mentality the don't do well
the creativity the excitement The Joy it
is not doesn't suit maintenance which is
why
entrepreneurial-minded folks struggle in
a corporate environment does that mean
you're changing does that mean that
you're in a position of no creativity or
not feeling challenged like
so what board is a very interesting
choice of words yeah so let me let me
I'll give you an example of something
let me just take my podcasting business
it's about 30 people it's called the
diver CEO and everything is going up
until and to the right so this month is
our highest standards ever we're going
to do about 35 million downloads this
month 400 000 new subscribers on YouTube
this month Spotify everything's going up
into the right and I know that it's in
those moments because I know this from
I'd say two and a half Decades of
observational analysis of my mother of
successful people of Joe Rogan of all
the people that were big and then fell
off I know that it's in those moments
when temptation to lose focus is the
highest so it's it's in those moments
when everything is going great that you
need to have this kind of boring
patience with the process and it's this
slow iterative one percent finding of
marginal gains that feels boring because
I'm not accepting huge new opportunities
that might divert my focus I'm doing in
fact what I think Joe Rogan did so well
which is do the same thing for 15 years
and don't allow yourself to be weighed
by
um Temptation which is as I said optimal
when things are going well give me an
example of a person or an organization
that you believe gave into temptation
like what does that mean like a specific
name of a person I mean or a company I I
can talk broadly about I mean the point
is it's like we're talking about these
things abstract yeah so help me
understand a tangible examples that I
can relate to what giving into temp
Temptation looks like the biggest
YouTuber in our country in the UK yeah
had let me say three three million
subscribers he was the king of YouTube
he was the king of in-depth
conversations he was the king of um the
algorithms Etc he got so big that he got
so many opportunities he got an
opportunity to start a fighting Channel
he got the opportunity to start a gaming
channel
um a football channel
um a second football channel loads of
other channels a gambling Channel he
took those opportunities he got an
opportunity to move to another platform
called twitch he took that opportunity
he lost focus and that the and he
slipped you slowly saw this descending
of of
um his his ability to reach people his
message
um he started he lost sight of also his
authenticity and would take
opportunities based on their
lucrativeness not not the residents that
I had with him in his audience and I
just watched him go from being the king
to being now completely you know texting
me the other day and asking me for a
loan because his his whole team have
left him and I I diagnosed that moment
against someone like a Joe Rogan who
doesn't get credit for really the
consistency and staying power and I go
it was in the moment when Temptation was
highest that he should have done
he should have made the toughest
decision which was to focus and I talk
about that a little bit in my book this
these moments in my life where I had
such high temptation to to lose focus or
my mother who I watched start 25
businesses between the age of between
the age of my age of 10 and 20. and I
watched how she was never successful
because whenever something showed any
sign of success or failure she would be
swayed by a narrative that there's
there's greener grass elsewhere and
watching your mother like our family
were we were virtually bankrupt for my
entire childhood no birthdays no
Christmases no driving licenses living
in a derelict house purely because of my
mother's lack of focus even the one
business she started which is this
restaurant that went remotely well she
was immediately swayed by someone down
the street telling her that an estate
agent's business was better and then I
watched the restaurant crumble as she
tried to give 50 to two things when both
of her competitors in those Industries
are giving 110 to each so when I said
boring at the start of this I'm honoring
the fact that I know focus and focusing
on consistency and compounding and um
doing more of the same stuff is in fact
the path to the top there's this really
interesting boring section in the middle
of it when you've got to just say no a
lot and they always say you know when
you're unsuccessful and things aren't
going well say yes and when you're
really successful and things are going
well so you know I'm saying no to
everything and it can feel a bit boring
I guess what you're describing in the
example of the the British podcaster is
selling out right which is you you've
achieved a level of notoriety or you
have a number of followers that is now
appealing to other companies and
advertisers Etc and you say they dangle
money in front of you it's the focus the
selling of the focus that I think is the
the worst thing you know Charlie Munger
one of the greatest investors of all
time says
um never interrupt compounding interest
unless you absolutely have to like
that's one of the great rules of
investing never interrupt the process
when something is compounding and he
interrupted the process Yeah by shifting
his Focus yeah
and that's that's the chapter of my life
I'm in and it's it's difficult to speak
to teams in fact your work on um
thinking about infinite games and finite
games really helped me because yeah
you've then got to build a system that
is built for a long long chapter of your
life yeah you've got to build a company
culture and you've got to energize your
people and Inspire them away in a way
which is built for 10 years not 10
months and that's what I think a lot
about is how do I keep these people with
me for the next decade how do I keep
their enthusiasm up how do I keep them
in a sustainable culture did you always
know this when did you learn this when
was the conversion to being finite
driven you know hitting a number hitting
a score if I get this amount of money
that'll make me happy to now recognizing
that sort of boring is actually a
strategy so it was reading your book in
fact So reading about finite in infinite
games changed my first business in a
quite profound way because I realized
that we were aiming at things like
becoming the best in our in our industry
when we wanted to be number one make the
most revenue or whatever and I realized
that they was a both a lack of
fulfillment that would come with
achieving those goals but also
um it wouldn't stand our company the
best chance of succeeding over time
because we were unsustainable we were
too intense we were focused on
short-sighted goals we had short-sighted
incentives
um and then in 2000 I'm going to say
2019 I stood in front of my company and
presented a new way forward which I
called www dot which was our world goals
which means outside of bubbles our
welfare goals which is the people inside
of our walls and I can't remember the
third world welfare oh and our work
goals which is the work we do for the
clients that we have and these goals
were all infinite in in design
um and just because of that it it meant
that we were designing our company to go
for multi-decades
um motivation increased staff attrition
fell in terms of people quitting
um
our incentive structures changed our
client work changed we took on different
clients that could go with us over the
long term which are more lucrative and
and I've and that's kept with me ever
since so thank you oh I love that and
thanks for being an example of what an
infinite-minded company looks like yeah
so there's there's a detail in your own
growth in your own history as an
entrepreneur that I find really
interesting
um you know
um I'll give an analogy some people I've
had people come up to me and say can you
help me can you give me advice I want to
be a public speaker and I say well what
do you want to talk about and they go I
haven't figured that out yet and I sort
of you realize they've got it in the
wrong order which is you find yourself
compelled by an idea and then you figure
out a way to spread that message public
speaking being one of them so it was
always weird to me that somebody says I
want to be a public speaker I don't know
what I'm speak about and I think we see
that very often in in business owners
which is I want to make a lot of money I
want to be my own boss I'm looking for a
business I can start right and money
very often is the driver
if I hit this number I'll be happy for
this if I hit this number I'll feel
successful
be successful whatever
and I'm very curious about your rise
when you first you started your first
business before you went public what was
the motivation what was the drive as I
mean how old were you when you started
that business
I was 21 when I started that business
um it was a pivot from a business that I
started when I was 18 but yeah 21 when
when it was founded when it was
registered as a company
and what was the ambition what was the
drive
there's a it's multifaceted so there's a
personal Drive which is to become rich
yeah and that was very clear to me I I
needed to become rich why because I was
deeply insecure and riddled with shame
and um being you know being the only
pretty much any black hidden in all
white area growing up we were the weird
family in my view
um we as I said we lived in a derelict
house and values often decided by
comparison so you know if you look at
where I was getting my value from you've
got a perfect house next to us a perfect
family on the other side you have
another perfect white family with lots
of money next to ours then you have this
derelict house with me and my black
family inside of it where the grass is
six foot high everything about my
contact and my environment told me that
I was lower value and told me that I
wasn't enough so the things that
invalidate you when you're a kid often
become the things you seek validation
from as an adult and for me I was
invalidated by a lack of money by no
romantic interests by my my family being
quite bizarre
um my mother being particularly um
um interesting
um and that's what I wanted I wanted
normalcy so at 18 years old I write in
the front page of my diary that by the
age of 28 I'll make a million pounds a
Range Rover Sport will be my first car
I'll get a six pack and a girlfriend and
that was my orientation and my North
Star in life that was if I did all of
these things then I would be successful
and that was my that's the path I set
out to achieve and by 23 I had a Range
Rover Sport was my first car I had multi
multiple millions in the bank account
had a girlfriend and I was working out
and uh you know I didn't feel great to
say the least so then so 23 year olds 23
years old is a pretty young age a To Be
A Millionaire but but then to have
achieved one's goals on paper yeah and
not feel successful
so what happened like so you achieve
these things and then what happened I
realized that I've been lied to you by
some kind of narrative when I say lied
to I don't mean someone had lied to me a
narrative had lied to me at some point
along the way a narrative had told me
that upon our company going public that
morning when I went over to my phone in
the corner of the room that a marching
band might appear and maybe all of those
people that called me the n-word or
bullied me when I was a kid would appear
and apologize and say how great I was or
something you know I was I was I was
confused about
um I was confused about the nature of
fulfillment and who I was and why I
wanted what I was and I was riddled with
fake Ambitions I think that's what I
came to learn over the years was that my
ambitions were fake they were they
weren't ambition they were insecurity
and there's a big distinction and most
of our lives are dragged by insecurity
and shame they're not driven by ambition
and when you just it's it's a tragic
truth that most of us are going to have
to have our our Ambitions and our our
narratives fail us before we realize
that they're they're released and their
mirages and then they're false it's sort
of something that I think a lot about
how do we get people to realize that
these limiting beliefs and ideas that
are driving their lives are
um Illusions before they have to undergo
the pain to realize that themselves even
a little bit earlier when someone
offered to buy our company for a very
big eight-figure number me going home
and going on rightmove.com to look at
the houses I could buy then going on
AutoTrader and look at the car that I
could buy and looking into the image on
this screen and realizing that I would
be somewhat emptier I'd be somewhat
poorer for buying these things and I
couldn't quite it was an emptiness that
I could feel inside of me
um and then I met the guy that I wanted
to become I always think about this I
went and met the guy that I wanted to be
a friend of mine was still a friend to
this day billionaire seven Lamborghinis
outside of his house I slept in the
Louis Vuitton room which was just this
big room surrounded by these bags
um spent time with him that night till
5am and he opened up to me and um you're
deeply deeply lonely asked me to sleep
in bed with him that night this is a 35
year old man
um one of the most miserable people at a
fundamental level that I'd met and that
who that is who I was striving to become
so I had to go in search of something
else a new set of values to govern my
life what you said you you described
this as fake ambition yeah so then
what's real ambition because you did
make the distinction what's real
ambition if this is the fake ambition
yeah so real ambition is is is driven by
your intrinsic
um desires and passions and interests so
you know like I DJ Now and I do this
podcast these are things that I would do
irrespective of remuneration they're
attached to my like intrinsic motivation
the things that you would do for free
I would you might not do them for free
unless you're unfortunate enough to have
Surplus income but they're the things
that you know yeah you would choose to
do if in a world where you didn't you
didn't have to worry about money
so fake Ambitions are driven by the
pursuit of rewards and validation like I
wanted a Lamborghini and I wanted to
Range Rover Sport even though I'm not
interested in cars real Ambitions sound
like I want to go and play the violin in
the hills of Peru because I love the
violin it makes me feel great you know
um and and it's funny because I used to
think that
if I realized I was quote unquote enough
it would it would remove my ambition a
lot of people think this they think if
they if they go I've had you know people
like Gary vaynerchuk and other people
I've interviewed say that if they
they're scared to go to therapy because
it because of what it might change in
them because of what it might remove
they think it will um steal their
ambition it doesn't steal your ambition
it steals your fake Ambitions and it
gives you and it gives you enough space
to focus on your real ones you've
achieved a tremendous amount and I think
what's what I enjoy what I really enjoy
about spending time with you is for
somebody so young you have a tremendous
amount of perspective and wisdom you
know I'm
getting older now and I sort of I'm now
that person who I remember older people
would say to me but wait till you wait
till you appreciate what the world is
like when you're older you know
and I'm like that person now looks back
and be like oh I wish I knew that you
know do you have a sense
of what you still have to learn
at this you know at this age looking
forwards or
or is that an unknown to you that you're
gonna have to trip over and you know
fall on your face to find out so outside
of Parenthood which I I've come to
realize that I I'm not it's one of those
things that I realize I'm not going to
know anything about until it happens
um I would say
romantic relationships I still have a
ton to learn there I would say I'm still
slightly confused and insecure as it
relates to
self-worth I.E I do spend too much time
obsessing over metrics and I know that
there's still a fundamental link between
my my self-esteem and my self-worth and
these metrics and numbers which is which
is interesting it's and I I sat with
someone who's who wrote the book about
status or status I don't know how you
guys sit over here and he says we all
play status status would you say just
kidding I'm gonna say status we all play
status games I I was under the opinion
that I'd stopped playing them I'd sold
all my fancy things I didn't have
designer stuff so I assumed I'd stop
playing status games in my life and he
made the case to me that your games just
change billionaires it's you know when
you're when you don't have a lot of
money the logos are bigger when you
become a billionaire as smaller logos
but bigger Yachts people with cameras
they play you know if my cameraman
walked in now he'd start talking about
the cameras in this room and trying we
all have these different games we're
playing and I'm playing a different set
of games now and I don't want to be a
slave to the game
um I want to be conscious of the things
that I'm doing and making sure that I
don't find myself in a similar position
where
um I'm trading happiness for I think I'm
trading happiness for my self-worth
that's still an ongoing challenge I have
and then I have other challenges like I
have a lot to learn about emotional
regulation
tell me more I find it easy to get
annoyed at things not I'm never angry I
don't shout it's not my style but I find
it easy ah
specifically as it relates to work
things and you said this on stage do you
remember I almost spoke yeah you said I
get very very annoyed at small details
not being right yeah as it relates to
work and standards and and that's
something that I know that I want to I
want to improve I want to be able to
take a little bit of a pause before
reaction you you said you still Harbor
insecurities and have self-worth issues
based on hitting metrics say more about
that like where where do you feel like
like where does if you you're happy you
wake up every day with gratitude and yet
it seems uh paradoxical or oxymoronic
that you you still struggle with
self-worth issues related to metrics
yeah I I don't
it's paradoxical but it's not because
both are definitely true so it's
definitely true that I wake up every day
with this like deep sense of gratitude
and disbelief in my life like it's every
day
um but at the same time my obsession
with being successful like making things
better finding marginal gains everywhere
to the point that it frustrates me and
this obsession with like climbing and
being better feels like it's still
rooted in in the same old issues for my
childhood
and it's just about being for me it's
about being conscious of that and having
a healthy relationship with that Pursuit
and again it being driven and not
dragged tell me
um a project that you've been involved
in professionally
that you absolutely loved being a part
of it doesn't it may or may not have
been commercially successful
but if every project you ever worked on
was like this one you would up you would
be the happiest person alive something
specific
the Diary of CEO the podcast okay so
what what specifically about Diary of a
CEO yeah it's the it's I mean the
Japanese referred to as Eureka guy right
something that I think I can get good at
I believe it's helping other people
um it's remunerative for me and I enjoy
the process
so it ticks all four boxes in that
regard seems to be my ICA guy as the
Japanese would say
um and this is definitely the thing that
I found in my life that that checks all
these boxes a lot of my businesses I
know that I'm running them for
commercial incentives it's taking a
curiosity box but it's really for a
commercial means um an end but the diary
this year would be the one is there a
particular guest or episode or series of
guests that
that capture that feeling better than
anybody else
so many of them um obviously all of our
ones when you that third episode we had
for me is a perfect example of that
where you have a human being you get to
meet a human being and it's at its that
human being's essence you get to learn
things that are resonant and that make
you feel like your struggle
um isn't because you're inadequate it's
because you're a human too and you're
given a path through your struggle
um there's humor in there
um there's you know a range of emotion
in there those are my those are my
favorite things and if I go right down
to when I was a kid I was I was strange
I would go in on first dates and I would
ask them deep questions about their
childhood
um if I had a tour guide and he was
telling me I remember in being in Peru
and the tour guide was showing me
buildings and for seven days I showed no
interest and on the seventh day he
started talking about how different
cultures that he takes on the tours have
different levels of happiness and he had
my undivided attention and he said to me
that on that seventh day says you
haven't paid attention for six days and
on the seventh day when I started
talking about people you tuned in that
is it's just clearly in school you know
two lessons that I I went to and didn't
get expelled from were psychology and
business all the other lessons my my
tenants hit 31 and that's why they
kicked me out so I would steal this
psychology books because I wanted to
take them home and read them so I've
always had a an Inc you know a focus on
human beings and why they do what they
do and so this is just
proven to be the perfect uh
solution to that what is tell me an
early specific
happy childhood memory something I can
relive with you running around in the
garden with my brothers playing having a
water gun fight was that one one water
gun fight you're talking about or
something you did one particular one I
got to remember okay tell me about what
what of all the magical things and I
know you had a weird childhood but of
all the magical things that happen as a
child what is it about this one thing
that that you're choosing to tell me
about it now freedom of any worries just
felt I just felt the son of my son on my
body running around through the garden
our house at this point wasn't
dilapidated my parents were still
on in reasonable terms with each other
um and yeah it was Freedom it was
sunshine I was away from school I didn't
really like school it was freedom and
that freedom is something I've pursued
my whole life absolutely in an
unrelenting way where I I do believe
you've done things where you played in
the garden before you did things where
you played with your friends where you
had a sense of Freedom you know what was
it about this one where you're playing
with your brothers that just seems to be
perfect that day I don't know why it
seems like everything there was ease and
there was so much disease in my
childhood there was so much screaming
and shouting this particular day just
seems to be very easy everything there
was you know everything was there the
sun was there my family were there they
seemed to be happy the house wasn't was
fine wasn't any worry and I was free
and that freedom is really why I'm an
entrepreneur I'm just very not very good
at being
constrained
in any way
I'm a remarkably good quitter it's one
of my my greatest skills has been better
than everyone I know at quitting say
more about that I just think I'm a
really really good quitter I look I
reflect on my meaning you know the right
time to quit or you just quit too
quickly quit too easily
um know the right time to quit but it's
more sort of intuitive and instinctive
than that quit with such ease and such
little worry about
um the path forward or what I'm the path
behind me
um and yeah that's really it I think
quitting the real skill of quitting
isn't necessarily knowing because you
can't know but it's it's knowing that
um you can't tolerate the the current
situation it's knowing that uncertainty
is is a better better hand to have than
misery but what about living as a Young
Generation now that quits very easily
yeah you know uh and they seem to be
following your Council which is this
sucks
um I could go talk to somebody but they
probably won't listen to me so what
would be the what's the point of going
to talk to somebody who you know doesn't
care about me anyway I'm just gonna like
everything you're saying can be
rationalized and used to justify
quitting regularly to the point of too
much and too easily well I think like
where's the new ones I think the key
point the key point of difference is I'm
saying when you when you think about the
fight to change something you have to
weigh up the rewards on offer you don't
lead a fight to change something in your
job if the rewards on offer are still at
the other end of that a job that you
absolutely hate you know
um or if you think that all the effort
it would take would still leave you with
a job you hate you fight for something
when you believe that the fight is
worthy of the eventual cause and so if
you're a gen Z and you're 19 years old
and you've got working conditions you
don't like but you believe it's possible
that that change in this organization is
achievable and if that you achieve that
change it wouldn't suck then you fight
for it but but I don't believe it's it's
right to fight for something where you
know that even if you win the rewards
aren't worth the fight so that's kind of
what I'm saying and to be fair what
you're describing is Gen Z's who just
don't like a situation so they leave
um and I believe it's the Nuance as well
as it relates to gen Z's and work and
culture is when you're young and I talk
about this as well a little bit my book
is you should really be focused on
filling these first two buckets which
are your Knowledge and Skills
irrespective of I believe the resources
the reputation and the network you get
from the role I think those are the most
important things I talk about these
first five buckets in your life
um knowledge being the first one which
is what you know skills which is what
you can do
um resources which is what you have the
network which is who you know and your
reputation which is what the world
thinks of you it's really those those
first two buckets that are gonna are the
most important and it's all five buckets
that are going to decide the course of
your life the example I give is of my
friend in San Francisco was was in his
front porch and a guy comes running
towards him sweating and you know and
and saying he's building these rockets
and putting these chips in people's
brains then he runs off and well my
friend told me that I was like my first
knee-jerk reaction was that is a
psychopath that is had escaped from an
asylum my friend said it was Elon Musk
and the minute you know that it's
because of elon's reputation and all of
that those five buckets that he's paid
into
um the world is the world is you know
the world is his oyster and I think
young people what sometimes they'll do
is they'll choose reputation or they'll
choose resources which is money or
remuneration in any regard
or they'll choose Network being working
with with them in a place that you know
is a surrounded by cool people versus
Knowledge and Skills and I would implore
all young people to focus on jobs that
give them Knowledge and Skills the first
the two buckets that no one can ever
take from you no professional earthquake
can empty those buckets tell me some
feedback that you got for example the
Diary of a CO team which is 30 people we
now have 360 interviews yeah because I
read things in an exit interview for a
different company and I had no idea that
person felt that way why didn't I ask
yeah yeah I had absolutely no idea so is
that why you built in the 360 so you can
get that information and also trying to
dissuade people to join the company
before they before we interview them you
think you think of interviews as a place
where you're selling yourself because of
these ex interviews and because I know
that our culture is so clear yeah and
non-negotiable in many respects I I
really try and dissuade people from
joining at the very start now so what do
you say I'm just very honest about the
way that we work which is and the
expectations is um we're a team that are
absolutely absolutely sweat the small
stuff yeah in every regard um we work in
the office
um we have we have what we call Freedom
within parameters so these are the
parameters of our working environment
we're in on Mondays we're in on Fridays
we're in most of the time and then
you're given Freedom
um to make your own decisions so if
you're not internet I have no idea where
you are no one's going to ask you if
you're not in for three days I have no
idea where you are no one's going to ask
you you're totally trusted in that
regard but we need these parameters
because we believe in synchronous
collaborative work as well and I laid
out this Manifesto to my teams which I
sent to them
um basically saying that we're going to
be in the office but but the key thing
was explaining why the underlying values
and principles as to why we're in the
office and how that links back to us
achieving these big Ambitions that we
all want to win at and in there it says
some you will do the best work of Our
Lives sometimes in a coffee shop or on a
beach and we'll do some of it in in the
office it's a hopefully it's a nuanced
thing
um and I really I'm really clear on that
but my biggest thing in teams and
Company building is culture
like I I the older I've got in business
The more I've realized that my job is
simply to hire the best people in the
world and buying them with a culture
that makes one plus one equal three and
it's my obsession it's I'm so obsessed
with it you wouldn't believe it
I'm absolutely obsessed with it which is
how to get a group of people to behave
in a manner that is conducive with best
outcomes and that's also links to my
obsession of psychology and
um I write a lot about this in in my
Birkin I've studied it a lot and I've
spoken to the the best you know managers
in the world at Big sports teams and
their players and I've learned so much
in this department
I don't know if you've noticed but I'm
channeling my inner Stephen Bartlett oh
listening have you ever I'm just I'm
just sort of sitting here and letting
you yeah that's when you do your thing
that's my thing what I think is
interesting which is I love the I think
to tell somebody up front that we sweat
the small stuff right
what I'm curious about you as a leader
is you grow as a leader especially when
scale starts to show up you know when
you have you know 30 people becomes 50
people because 80 people in terms of a
thousand people you know
um well you don't actually know
everybody's name anymore and you don't
recognize everybody's face you don't you
know you walk through a hall and like
you don't even know the people who work
for you yeah you know I've been there
I've seen you sweat the small stuff and
you and I are very very different in how
we split the small stuff
and I'm very curious how do you know the
impact on your team
the way you sweat the small stuff
like what Ripple effects it has
I'm not I'm not criticizing sweating the
small stuff no no no that's great in
what regard are they able to sweat the
small stuff when you're sweating the
small stuff for them
ah okay so should I give you a real life
example yeah it's the example I mean we
talked about it a little bit but when we
did our charity show at the Royal
Festival Hall
the mix on the music was all wrong
the music overshadowed our voices which
is the intro music before we came on and
I knew it and you knew it and we said to
the team
that needs to be fixed
and you sat in the audience and
kept pushing and kept pushing and kept
pushing and I was watching you sweat the
small stuff I don't know if you notice
but I sort of like
walked away I went and did my own thing
and not because I thought oh Steven's
got this under control
it's because the way I do that is
different
and
my attitude is and it's not right or
wrong and this is what I think is
interesting
which is I sweat the small stuff by
saying in no uncertain terms this must
be fixed before we go live and then I
expect them to fix it like I've said my
thing it's a team of professionals know
what they're doing and then I leave it
be
but I I watched what happened I don't
know if you know this is because you
were sweating the small stuff
it increased the level of stress
and the people who are professionals who
know exactly what they're doing
were now became vendors
moving a level up a moving a level down
because you told them to not because
they said I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
try this and see if that works they
became order takers
and we got the product but my question
is at what cost and for one night
whatever right but when it's your own
team the question is is that sustainable
and how does that make somebody feel
over the course of time when absolutely
create a culture where you expect them
to sweat the small stuff
and the analogy I'll give
isn't is is a military analogy where
there's something called commander's
intent
where the commander says I want this
accomplished
and then walks away
and it's up to the team to figure out
how to get it done and to get it done to
the satisfaction of the commander but
the commander doesn't say have you tried
this do this now try this wait that
didn't work do this over here right
um and what they're doing is building
confidence
and leaders in their wake
versus
order takers
and
uh
creating environment where
where confidence might actually not grow
so I I I so that specific example is a
good one so I arrive in the the hall
right we've got an hour to go right
um done multiple shows myself the last
one I did there was real issues with
sound and Acoustics yeah so that's on my
mind got it I sit down they play it
nobody seems to this is my uh
this is not my team yep so I have no
idea about their behaviors whether they
are whether I can say something to them
and it will change instantly I don't
have that level of confidence I've never
met these people before I hear it and
there's a clear issue with the audience
yeah it's bad and I said I know that the
last time I let that slide I then woke
up in the morning to 27 messages across
LinkedIn and Instagram of people really
unhappy if I had spent 70 pounds to come
to a show that's front of mind for me
that LinkedIn message that essay that
girl sent me from Glasgow who had
traveled down from Glasgow to see this
show then because of an audio issue we
had she she sent me an essay telling me
she had a bad time that's Weighing on my
mind so I communicate that I
um think it needs to be better they play
the new sound and I still think it's not
good enough correct it seems like some
people around me think it's good enough
yeah it doesn't meet my standard yet
yeah so I say
um it's not quite there they play it
again it's not quite there it again
seems to me that people around me are
okay with that standard it's not okay
for me right for me it has to be there
they play it again it seems to me like
some p people around me would would at
that point say that's good enough yeah
not not for me yeah because I'm thinking
about Rebecca who sends me the LinkedIn
message with the essay tomorrow morning
yeah when she comes out and she couldn't
have heard it and she's traveled from
other another country we had people
coming from other countries so my
decision was I will I will sit there and
I'm not telling these audio people to do
because I've got a clue what that what
they're doing and I'll just say when I
think that I can hear the audio clearly
yeah and eventually it got to a point
where it was about 80 and they said
we'll continue to work on it and then I
walked away yeah and that's that's the
that's how I am is I I am if you work
with me you'll know that there's a
standard and I've seen you know you
asked me the question how does this
impact the people around me I genuinely
believe that when you look at the
podcast trailers yeah that we have
you've told me you think they're the
best yeah and you you said to me as well
that your team are trying to emulate but
yeah that's that's what it is it's we
sit there sometimes on Sunday night till
2 A.M tweaking one second
because we that is both the controllable
thing and it's the thing that most teams
don't care about they go to bed they
walk away for sure so it's my it's my
belief and I say this a lot in the book
that fighting for the most used phrased
in my office is one percent because we
are it's our religion if we were to get
hoodies they would say one percent on
the back of them we believe that it's
the small things that most people don't
care about that are the things where the
most accessible and important games are
made so that audio for me was one thing
I could control it was getting that
right an hour before the show and when
we walked out it was perfect it was do
you want to know how I dealt with that
situation because I dealt with it
simultaneously with you I was also very
very unsatisfied and it had to be good
for all the same reasons I know people
are traveling in people are paying good
money
um uh I know it's a special event and
you and I have the same very high
standard that we want people to walk
away going
that was so worth money and two hours of
my life and I'm so so glad I went like I
want them to feel that they got the
better half of the deal every time I
went to the senior person there the one
who whose reputation is on the line for
putting this show on and I leaned into
them and said this is not good I said
this has to be better so I didn't know
who they were right I had no idea who
any of these people were so for me I was
like I can't trust people that I've
never ever met professionally to deliver
upon a standard when it's when I was
like the people that are coming are
tagging me on Instagram so that's the
moment and uh had I not had a show
recently where there was an audio
problem and there was a big backlash
which I had to answer for
um or if it was my team when I turned to
my team and I said we have to get this
right if I'd said that to my team I
could have walked away so
but if I say that to the team I've never
met I'm gonna sit and make sure so I'll
tell a story yeah so I did this thing
for the Disney imagineers a bunch of
years ago I was just giving a talk about
why and start with why and they wanted
to see what it meant to start with why
and so I picked a random guy in the
audience to do a y Discovery with
and I picked at somebody with gray hairs
because I figured he'd had a little a
little experience and kind of knew his
thing and unbeknownst to me I found this
out afterwards the guy I picked his
nickname in the company and I'm not even
sure if he knew this was ice chips
because he was a cold bastard
right so I picked on ice chips and I
started asking him to give me a specific
example of what it meant to be an
imagineer like what what why was so
important
and he told this story over the course
of many minutes I'll give you the very
quick version of a new ride that he had
overseen the building of
and he went to see the opening of the
ride and at the opening there was a guy
in a wheelchair with his kid waiting to
go on the ride
and he said anywhere in the world
everyone would see a guy in a wheelchair
with his son
only at Disneyland
do we only see
a father and his son at Disneyland
we don't see and we've made it like you
talk to people who are in wheelchairs
just how seamless and how easy
Disneyland is
and his intensity
is because it mattered so much to him
that that person never felt like a guy
in a wheelchair that he only felt like a
dad with a son at Disneyland
and we're all crying and an instant
everyone understood why he was such a
cold bastard it's because to him the
stakes were that high in an instant
those who worked for him who up 10
minutes before hated working for him now
loved working for him in an instant more
people wanted to work on his team
because they wanted to be held to that
standard
and the
I think that people with high standards
should obviously continue those high
standards but I think there's value in
sharing a specific story of a specific
person maybe it's a girl from Glasgow or
the converse something affirmative
that helps people understand
why
you come in like a bull in a china shop
because it makes them want to support
you and I don't mean you I mean a leader
and it makes them proud
to
lift the quality of their work and push
harder for that one percent rather than
feel that no matter what they do they
can't do anything right and I've been on
your side I've been the one who's come
in and said no no and I've sat there and
pushed and pushed and pushed and it was
only until a lot later in my career that
I learned that what I was doing is
making somebody feel that they can't do
anything right and I appreciate you said
it's different for folks on your team
yeah because so the reason when I was
talking earlier about these um tax
interviews you'll notice that I said I
switched from the Diary of a CO team
which is about 30 people to saying
another company's exit interview yeah
because no one's ever left and part of
the reason that I think no one's ever
left the driver's Co team in the four
and a half years that we've started
since we start the company no one's ever
quit the company is because we're so
grounded in our sense of purpose to the
point that every day we start with our
impact chat which is the the screenshots
or the messages we've received from
people all around the world or we watch
a little clip of someone that's come up
to us in the street and said
um about their darkest time and how what
the work we're doing has has been
pivotal to them the team will watch the
episodes they all we all spend an hour
every week going through um the most
meaningful points of feedback we've had
we all I feel this sense of
responsibility and when we're talking
about when I show the metrics to the
team which we do we did this week it's
all framed against impact it's all
framed against Joanna who came up and
told us about the loss of her son and so
and it feels like this responsibility
that we're holding as a unit together
which means that the work like and also
do you know when I talked about
um the trailers and stuff yeah yeah I
said Saturday night 1am yeah one of my
things is you
you sit in the trenches with with people
yeah so when if if I'm asking ant to
make a correction last minute because
something it one word in the trailer
isn't quite hearable I'm gonna sit with
that until I am yeah on Saturday night
I'm not gonna tell Aunt to to make that
edit and then go to bed or leave so I
will sit in the studio even if I'm
useless just to show that we're doing
this together that's so important to me
and when we're thinking about that
moment in in the theater at the charity
event there's part of that in it as well
which is there's the trust issues that I
have because I don't know these people
um there's this fear of Rebecca's gonna
send me the LinkedIn message and we're
going to ruin her trip if she can't hear
it yeah and then there's this third
point which is I actually think I'd be
more of an [__] to say something and
walk off the thing that I so I
appreciate about the way you've built
the Diary of a CEO the company
is how and I think a lot of companies
don't do this which is you are very
clear about what it's like to work here
and you're going to say you're setting
expectations up front this is what it's
going to be like if you don't like that
please don't work here because this is
what it look and it's a lot more
sophisticated than we work hard play
hard like which is nonsense I've never
believed in that as an aside you know
that both of that sounds very both of
those sound very unhealthy working hard
some you know it's like work smart play
always you know but that's an aside
and then the expectations are set and
somebody doesn't like it then they knew
that up front and I and and I think that
very often what happens when companies
are interviewing they're selling
themselves just as the potential
employee is selling themselves and they
make it out to be incredible and we have
fun all the time and it's amazing and
it's and it's fun all the time and it's
easy all the time well that's not how
any company is ever and so what I love
is the way you set expectations up front
and you know what as well and I'd love
that and then you and then you simply
say I'm going to hold you to the
standard that I told you about on day
one enjoy or day negative one do you
know the most motivating thing I think
for people in work is and I've come to
learn this is um is progress yeah and
when the reason why maybe Sophie my
assistant who's been with me for eight
years pretty much my whole career hasn't
left it's because she feels like she is
on a rocket ship yeah and when Harvard
Business Review interviewed 1500
employees and asked them what their best
days in work were it was always the days
when they had a sense of progress yeah
and I know that progress comes from
those one percent marginal gains so
David browse fit when I when I
interviewed him he talks about how the
you know making one percent gains
improves your sales numbers or your
performance on the bicycle in the
Olympics or whatever but the more
important thing that no one understands
he said to me is when you create the
impression amongst a group of people
that they are going somewhere that they
are moving he says that was the thing
that changed our our fortunes when he
became the head of performance at the
Olympic cycling team and took them from
being the worst cycling team of all time
to the best ever and holding all the
records he said it was the sense of
progress this sense that we're going
somewhere together that did it not the
gains the psychological sense of
progress and so we call it the progress
principle which is
um yeah I think I reflect on that and go
this is why I think if you spoke to the
30 people individually and said is this
and we kind of do this in our 360
feedbacks now is this the best job
you've ever had I think 95 of them would
say yes because we feel together
collectively yeah like we're going
somewhere and more importantly it's
somewhere we want to go somewhere that
matters and it's something other than
money yeah yeah because progress can be
like look at our growth because I think
a lot of companies want to do that right
okay I just I just want to be let's I'm
just being clear for people that we're
not talking simply about no you know
forward motion and I think if you want
to make people happy and work they need
challenge yeah right this is why in game
psychology games get increasingly more
difficult you wouldn't do the same
um difficulty of crossword over and over
again you want a sense of challenge to
keep you engaged Daniel pink right
interview talks about challenge being
critical to motivation yeah they need
that sense of Forward Motion which is
the progress principle that sense that
we're going forward together so you've
got to keep people challenged healthy
amount of Challenge and it's different
for everybody you know we're all
swimming at different depths already so
it's just that one step forward into
that discomfort Zone you want to be
working with a group of people that you
genuinely believe care about you which
means that they care about you beyond
the professional um output
um you want autonomy in your work if you
have a sense of control and freedom
which I believe that the people in my
team do although we have high standards
and high expectations
um and lastly maybe most importantly of
all you want to believe that the place
you're going is subjectively worthwhile
so for Holly and my team yeah if you
asked her why she loves this job it
won't be the same yeah that's why Sophie
loves it yeah or why will loves it yeah
totally different reasons but they've
all got a reason and it's a worthwhile
reason and if you have those five things
and your team members I think um it's
hard it's hard to lose people that when
you have all those five things going for
you the thing that I think distinguishes
you from other not just young
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs and business
people is you know there was this 80s
90s model that was formed that
perpetuated up until today about the
hard-nosed you know uh business leader
who you know believes in progress and
growth you know uh pushes people because
we we have high standards and in to some
degree is
um is always
um there's a lack of vulnerability
because the vulnerability is weakness
yeah and you're um you still represent a
lot of the you know you're successful
you're young you're you're you have
ambition you're driven you believe in in
very very high high standards
um and yet you are very comfortable
being very open about your struggles
your uncertainty
um you know a crazy screwed up childhood
you know that you're very open about
um unresolved issues struggles with
relationships feelings of inadequacy
still unhealthy connections to metrics
to some degree that you're still working
through and you're very comfortable
presenting yourself as a work in
progress
um and you know I wanna I think that the
message that you spread and the fact
that you have been as successful as you
are as young as you are I think quite
frankly and I and I sort of push you on
this a little bit at the beginning I
actually do think that you are leading a
new movement what the future of business
and Business Leaders
could look like and should look like
[Music]
um
um that the two are not mutually
exclusive that being a human being
goes along simultaneously with
commercial success
it's not either or they go together in
fact they're healthier together yeah and
I I just want the best
outcome in my personal life my mental
health and in my business and it's my
belief that high standards are
non-negotiable if you want to be
successful and it's and again why does
success matter I've explained that in
part but I've explained why the success
of the team also keeps people motivated
and in my personal life if I want to be
happy and successful in my personal life
then I also need to be open and I need
to be honest and I need to be a human
being honest with myself first and
foremost which allows me to be honest
with others allows me to be open enough
to have relationships with a woman who
you know can connect with me so
um I hope that the byproduct everything
you've detailed there is because I'm
trying
to be
um I'm trying to be successful I'm
trying to be successful in myself and in
my business and by the way I know saying
that I have high standards and work is
like I know some people think it's like
a toxic thing or whatever I'm like well
aware of that but I also have studied
hundreds and hundreds of successful
teams I've interviewed 10 Manchester
United players under Sir Alex Ferguson
and this biggest CEOs in the world all
of them and I know that I know a couple
of truths I know that people do want to
do the best work of their lives the
right type of person yeah I know that
there's no company or great team in the
world that's ever got there without high
standards and unnegotiable values the
best companies in the world the best
leaders in the world it's not that they
just have high standards which they do
but they make it abundantly clear the
culture that you're walking into I've
also ran the test so like I've got
multiple companies that I have this
bird's eye view on and I see these these
um I see the companies that have high
dissatisfaction but I'm an investor in
yeah I'm on the board and I see the it
tends to be the case when there's lack
of clarity regardless yeah either way if
it's remote working or if it's in the
office five days a week the the biggest
disease is lack of clarity yeah and then
people can choose and the worst company
cultures in companies that I invest in
um are the ones that where they have
weak leadership in terms of giving
Clarity and setting expectations
regardless of what the expectations are
or regardless of what the working
Dynamics are and so with my thing in my
companies if I'm the CEO if I'm driving
the company you're gonna know you're
going to know exactly what's expected of
you you're going to know exactly what
our cultural values are and I'm going to
defend it like no one has ever defended
it that you've ever seen yeah and if you
speak to people that work for me like
the CEO of one of my companies called
flight
um the company's called flight story he
will recite moments where I acted
totally against the company's short-term
objectives yeah in a way he could not
understand to defend our values and our
culture of kindness yeah even though we
needed this person and we're going to
lose a client if we let this person go
me finding out that they did something
to a junior member of the team they
spoke to them in such a way which I
think is unacceptable I removed them
which means we lose the client fine and
I remember the conversation that day
with Oliver saying I'd rather not have a
company with my name attached to it than
allow that behavior to exist anywhere in
any of these walls it's a violation and
if we allow that violation it's like a
frog in a frying pan it will slowly
creep on you it's like a disease so this
is why I said earlier on I'm obsessed
with culture because for me I'm clear
and it's unnegotiable and we do the best
work of Our Lives we do great great
stuff we really we do we out fail all of
our competition which is really the key
to becoming successful I think
especially in a world that's changing at
lightning pace and is only increasing in
Pace of change
um what does that mean
like you know so if you I remember
reading about I think it's um Ray
kurzwell he's the you know eminent
futurist in the world and he says
because of the rate of change if you're
11 years old now you're going to
experience
a Year's change in if you're 10 years
old now you'll experience a Year's
change in 11 days by the age of 60. Ray
Kurzweil says that will experience 20
000 years of change in the 21st century
which is a hundred times more than the
previous
um rate of rate of change in the
previous Century we're going into a
world that's changing faster than ever
where books and
typical sources of information aren't
going to give you the answers so how do
you find the answers to key questions in
podcasting marketing business sales
processes when the world is changing so
quickly well you have to be failing
faster than your competition and that's
a philosophical thing it's a behavior
thing it's a culture thing how do I get
my team to out fail the competition if I
if we do
um then we're going to arrive at the
right answer continually faster than
everybody else so if I if I you know
because podcasting is a good example
um I can show you on my phone now the
Diary of a CO translated into every
language in the world and two-way
conversation so you're speaking in Simon
sinek's tone but in Italian I can show
you that on my phone right now because
we've done it I can show you the tool
we've built to a B test 40 thumbnails at
the same time before the episode comes
out and then when it comes out it tests
eight every hour and I it's like you
know so with with we're conduct we
haven't I disappointed this week ahead
of experimentation
and I know that these and it goes back
to my obsession with these one percent
games I know we're gonna fail our way
faster to the right answers across the
businesses that I run and that's why I'm
sure we'll be number one because our
rate of failure is significantly faster
than every other team because of culture
Dynamics a lack of bureaucracy
empowerment uh smaller teams
um incentivizing the experiment not the
outcome of the experiment conducting
type 2 decisions faster than everybody
else decisions that are reversible
realizing that time is in fact usually
the biggest cost in decision making not
the outcome
um and that's that's the way we operate
and it's always worked for us and it's
I feel like I have I feel like in that
regard I have like a uh I feel like I
have a secret
I feel like I have a secret to business
which is most people are you know that
they're messing around and trying to
make big steps forward my obsessive
belief is that it's the tiniest small
steps forward that I discovered through
failure and higher rates of
experimentation that make all the
difference and it's little it's little
because little little failures are not a
big deal and I think people are so
afraid of failure but the problem is
they're thinking they're thinking of
large steps big decisions small quick
things more quick things constant
constant Improvement I I over the years
I spent 10 years working in marketing so
I would sit in these board rooms with
CEOs and there was this father and son
they run two different brands and under
the same company gonna call it dad's
brand Sons brand now when I took an idea
if I you know there was this one moment
where I figured out a loophole in
Instagram where we could grow a
following cheaper than anybody's ever
grown it before and I took it to the dad
and the Sun the dad I present the idea
to him he's arguing about the cost he's
he wants evidence nine months of him
deliberating whether to proceed with the
idea I take the idea to the sun the sun
would always say hear the idea he'd say
Jenny go and get Nikki and the entire
team call them into the room and say
Steve repeat what you just said to me
and I'd repeat the idea and he'd say
we're going to do it now no contracts no
worry about the money how much we're
going to get paid he says we're going to
do it now and what and we'd conduct the
experiment and in that particular case
it gave them 13 million Instagram
followers now why do I say this story
this is not a one-off this would happen
this happened for five years with me
working with the dad and the son two
billion dollar companies the the
conclusion of the story is the son's
business overtakes the dad's business
and is now the biggest business in the
space the moral of the story is the sun
intuitively knew that the cost wasn't
um the 20K the cost was time wasted
procrastination and the missed
opportunity he also knew that in the
grand scheme of things
that really What mattered more was
getting on to the next experiment and
Amazon are the prime example of this the
fire phone that this they have a
graveyard of failed experiments but then
they have AWS and you have to and it's
one in 20 and you don't know when it's
coming like a slot machine so it's
really getting 320. the sun knew we
needed to get onto the next experiment
if that experiment had failed the next
day we're on to the next experiment and
then so he's going to conduct 20
experiments in the nine months that the
dad is deliberating one experiment it
was the rate of experimentation and I
just watched him wipe the floor with his
father and people that know me will know
who I'm talking about wipe the floor
with his father because of speed of
experimentation
um so I think about that a lot now get
all of the things out of your way that
are slowing your rate of experimentation
and measure it and I mean the Kaizen
philosophy which I write about at Great
length in my book is a prime example of
this
um
which shows it's all about empowering
the people at all levels and Innovation
isn't the job of the c-suite empower the
people on the production line
um incentivize them and measure the
amount of experiments they're conducting
and then in the case of Toyota who are
still leading the world in Auto
production you'll get
a hundred thousand times more ideas from
all levels of your company than your
Western counterparts which will drive
efficiencies Drive profits up Drive
costs down reduce the amount of
absenteeism
um defects in the cars and everything
else and with the Kaizen philosophy in
particular which is this idea that
everybody at all levels in the
organization is responsible for
Innovation and it's a flatter
organization where you just have three
levels where you have like management
team leader and then leader they've
proven because they've taken over other
companies like GM Back in 1970 they took
over GM installed their culture and a
factory in America that had
2012 defects per vehicle had 20
absenteeism rates had a backlog of 5 000
grievances from their employees became
GM's best production facility in the
world with the same Workforce
with the same people they put a firing
freeze and it was just culture they went
from being the worst GM plant in the
world to being the best gym plant in the
world with a change of culture which was
centered on empowerment removing levels
of bureaucracy
um giving people the knowledge that they
needed and listening to people as well
here's what I've learned sitting with
you
um and I find this last bit absolutely
magical
which is
um
that
um you are everything about you is a
work in progress and what I mean by that
is you apply the same philosophies to
yourself as you do to your businesses
which is constant improving constant
Improvement
um constant self-evaluation constantly
looking for something new and the reason
being is when it works
you know those little glimmers because
they're glimmers because you get a
little break to see it work and then
you're back back in it that those limit
those little glimmers feel like
um
when you're in the backyard in the
garden with your brothers with the sun
shining and it's just effortless and
families is functional and and the
constant Improvement the constantly I'm
working on it is for these glimmers of
magic you know and the motivation is the
sun on your back with your friends and
the and you've spoken about this which
is the way you describe that experience
in the in the garden with your family is
the same way you described
when I ask you to give me a business
example that if every day was like this
you'd be the happiest person alive of
every project and you describe diary of
a Serie CEO and it sounded very much the
way you described your you except your
brothers were replaced by your team
and the Sunshine was replaced by sort of
that you're making an impact and the
even though everybody's working really
hard and even though you're running
around and everybody's sweating there's
this joy and effortlessness that comes
from it
um and at the end of the day it's about
family right it's about creating
that sense of family and people who
share in in the joy and this is what I
find absolutely magical about you which
is you're very unselfish about your
success
um you want to bring as many people you
want to bring the team with you the
diversity is a great example at the end
of last year we we took we show everyone
the bank account in the team so everyone
gets to see how the money's being spent
and then at the end of the year we take
last year I think it was 20 of what's in
the bank account and give it to the team
so it's a new way to build a company but
again it goes back to this thing of
trying to go for 10 years where you've
got someone who maybe got a size there's
people in the team whose size of bonus
at Christmas was the same size as their
salary and they're 21. and you give
handing over that check in my house
where we all met every single member of
the team including Sophie here who got
enough to pay off her mortgage at
Christmas she said
um was the best day of my career you
know it was generally the best day of my
career being able to do that build a
company where there's not like these
other shareholders and being able to pay
off Sophie's mortgage with a Christmas
gift that she wasn't expecting that's
you know that's the sunshine that's the
sunshine yeah that is it is we do run
like a family I mean like it's the
pursuit of sunshine yeah I think that's
what you do
yeah I still think I'm trying to figure
out what I do on it the pursuit of
sunshine is a nice way to sum it up and
I think about it a lot I just think more
broadly about humans why we struggle
like why are we why we need to climb and
why we need to achieve and human beings
are dopamine driven animals right for
good reason which is fine food fine
shelter find protection you know here I
found some food got it dopamine do it
again do it again
um uh
but that's only one half of how human
beings work but the problem is that's
um it's it's a it's a very tangible
thing dopamine is produced by tangible
outcome a metric that I can count food
that I can eat my keys that I lost now
that I've now found like here they are
that's dopamine you know like I won I
hit three sevens on the slot machine I
have you have to be able to see it you
know that's how you get that's how you
get it
um and we're very very tangibly driven
animals animals is a very powerful
motivator but it doesn't produce
feelings of Joy safety love which are
the other flip side and that's all of
that slow building chemical stuff of
Serotonin and oxytocin and the hard the
hard work of being human is maintaining
the balance and I I get I think this is
so funny as because we're we're animals
like all animals in Mother Nature cats
don't have to work very hard at being
cats they just they're cats but humans
have to work really hard at being good
at being human and we can screw it up so
badly and remember we're very old
machines we're a very Legacy machine
tens of thousands of years old operating
in a world that our bodies and our
systems were not designed for and the
and perhaps 50 000 years ago we didn't
have to think about how how to be a good
human being it probably was organized to
work but in this modern day and age we
have to because there's so many things
that will break the machine like think
about it in the west because there's so
much abundance you know we just go to
the supermarket you know like we
actually have to think about nutrition
like we have to think about what we
should eat and how we should eat that 50
000 years ago that never happened to you
whatever you found and by the way it was
fine you know
um it's because everything around us has
hijacked and broken the broken the human
being but I just get a kick out of the
fact that it's so hard to be a good
human
and
um and this idea of constant Improvement
for you is very very balanced on working
very very hard to be a good human being
be kind to those around you bring those
around you on the journey with you
bring you know share the sunshine with
the brothers the sunshine is paying off
the mortgage I just love that you do it
I think a lot of people talk about it
and we live in a world where
you know the hard-nosed business people
scuff at the people who talk about
kindness and generosity as business
philosophies and then you have the other
side of the sort of like the universe
will provide that scuff at people who
are driven by metrics and answers you're
both right you're both wrong it's both
it's it's both and
I do honestly believe you know where so
many CEOs look like Jack Welch today
which I think is abhorrent
um I'm bullish that in 10 or 20 years
that the majority of CEOs will look and
act like you and when
we talk about mental Fitness
when people struggles with mental
Fitness I think the antidote isn't
yoga
it's working
for people with people
who care about you and want to see you
succeed and succeed together
um you know the business is the modern
tribe yeah it's exactly that and and the
tribal leaders have a responsibility to
make sure that the tribe survives bad
weather
you know drought you know an attack from
another tribe an attack from another
wild animal
um
and
and it is very tribal I don't think
somebody older than you would have
figured this out and I hope that you
inspire people who are younger than you
on
how to do this right
I want everybody to read all your books
I want everybody to listen to your
podcast
you know when I think about the Diary of
a CEO
it's not the CEO part that matters it's
the diary part that matters it's the
self-reflection it's the recording it's
the Gratitude it's exactly why I chose
the name which is you don't often get to
see into the the Diary of a CEO no they
tend to keep it private so it almost
felt like a bit of a juxtaposition
something so secretive and Elusive and
somewhat guarded and then the diary
which is vulnerable and open and the
antithesis of that
um and then that's that's really what
I'm trying to do is trying to get people
to open their diary and to share the
wisdom the honesty and the vulnerability
that exists within it so you're good at
getting other people to open up their
Diaries
and you do it by demonstrating your
willingness to open up yours that is
true just as you said you'll stay up
till one o'clock in the morning with
your team and not ask them to do
anything that you wouldn't do you're not
asking anybody else to open up and
answer questions that you wouldn't
answer they wouldn't they wouldn't you
know when we first met if you've got the
impression that I was like
threatening or I'd like I was unwilling
to be equally open with you I don't
think you would we would have had the
conversations that we had when I say
Focus consistency and showing up every
day and trying to find a one percent
gain yeah this is why this is also why
we're not going to launch the podcast
Network which we spent 12 months and I
extended enough it's one of the biggest
CEOs in in the media world and then I
and I sat down with my team and I said
to them
and then I talk about this idea of this
pre-mortem analysis I said to my team
the day before I was gonna um sign off
this job offer for this guy to quit his
job at this big company and come and
join us to launch a big Global
podcasting network with all the skills
and knowledge we have I said why will
this fail
question I haven't asked a lot in my
career and there was this this pause
amongst my team
and then minutes later
boom reason one yeah reason two reason
three Focus we can't if we have
um Talent OR celebrities what if they
leave
um we'll lose sight we don't have enough
resources to run multiple podcasts we'll
lose like all of these reasons came out
and uh we did I made the decision after
12 months of work and spending hundreds
of thousands of pounds to not pursue it
and to go back to focus and you know I
think this is something that people
don't understand which is
um the momentum of a decision like just
because we spent time and energy
and there's there's this I think there's
a lot of leaders who are plagued by this
which is we have to do it why do we have
to do it because look how much time and
money we've invested you know but
there's a psychological bias which I
write about
um where they tested they basically got
a group of people as Ellie Aaronson a
psychologist the American psychologist
one of my favorite they've got a group
of people and they put them into a very
boring
um book club very very boring everyone
in there was purposefully intentionally
dull and then they asked them how good
the book club was and they all gave a
score so these people that are put into
there then they got another group of
people and they made them go through a
rigorous testing process and surveys to
get into the book club the people that
had done the rigorous testing and
surveys and applications to get into the
book club even know it was dull and
boring reported that the book club was
amazing and was much better than the
people that hadn't fought to get in
there and it speaks to this kind of like
sunk cost idea that leaders have where
just because we've worked hard on
something they tricked them themselves
into believing that it is good and then
it must be good that's it's a
psychological bias and that's what we're
done we'd spent a year working on
something so no one had stopped to pause
and ask ourselves why this is a really
bad idea we invested so much too much a
friend of mine I got he invited me to
sit in on his uh company All Hands which
he does I think like twice a year
and they just they have this rigorous
process where they go through everything
and it was amazing because I just sat
back and there's something that they do
that I absolutely love which is when
they invest in a company
they
um do an internal analysis which is what
are the three reasons we shouldn't
invest yeah right but he does it on his
own company too
he asked his own team what are the three
reasons someone shouldn't invest in US
right interesting and it doesn't matter
what's on the list
what matters is when they do it again
next time if the same things are still
on the list why and I think it's
important to say why this is so
important because what it does is it for
me is it changes my perspective it takes
me away from the painting sometimes
you're too close to the painting that
you can't see the picture Takes Me Away
from the painting and puts me in another
perspective where I can look at myself
yeah just that simple question and
immediately when you said that I I did
that with my company with my company
flights through my marketing business I
thought what's the reason why someone
shouldn't invest in it yeah and the
answer came to mind yeah well there's
you know he does three and again there's
another problem that none of those are a
problem the problem is if those that if
one of them continues to be on the list
that means you haven't addressed it
because what it does it reveals the
things that need to be fixed or
addressed so address them there's always
going to be reasons why people shouldn't
invest in you
um and I know we've done this analysis
on ourselves and the frustration is we
had one thing that kept showing up on
the list each time we did and we're like
okay we have a serious problem here that
this thing is always on the list you
know
um and so so that's our like our focus
is to address that thing
um but I love that test I love that test
which is the three reasons not to do
something because I don't think we do
that I think we talk about all the
upside and and I and you and I've talked
about this this before with which is the
cost of things and we don't mean money
which is everything in the world comes
at a cost there's a cost for the money
you make there's a cost for your
relationships and it's not for us to
weigh whether the cost is worth it like
if somebody thinks it's worth being
driven by the size of your yacht and the
you know the you know the size of your
plane and the size of your house and the
number of Lamborghinis you have front
and if the cost is I'm lonely I have no
relationships my all of my friendships
are deal friendships they're all
transactional friendships if that cost
is worth it then have at it like who
might have tell you the life that you
should or shouldn't live right but don't
wake up one morning and be surprised
that you're lonely and have no friends
you knew that going in and you decided
that was worth it now if you want to
make a change fine then be open about it
you know I thought it was worth it I
realized I was wrong it wasn't worth it
and so I'm a great believer in
evaluating the cost of things all the
time and asking myself was the cost
worth it and so you've made sacrifices
in your life for the for the life you
lead I've made sacrifices in my life for
the life that I lead and the way I
choose to build build my movement and
spread my message and if you ask me was
the cost worth it and it came at Great
personal cost of personal life and and
social life you know relationships and
the answer is yes yes it was worth it
because the thing that I care about I
was willing to pay that and other people
weren't willing to pay that but I was
and again it's not a it's not judgmental
or or it is all subjective to each
individual and they're no star and it's
a North star but the question but but
you have to say you have to be open and
honest with yourself about what is the
cost of this decision that I'm making I
also one of my favorite decision making
um criteria before I make a decision and
this is stupid little stuff even
sometimes you know it's interpersonal
stuff sometimes not just big business
decisions sometimes it's mundane little
stuff I'll always ask myself what good
will come of this decision
and if no good comes of this decision
then why are you making this decision
and sometimes you know it's like like
people who say like well what good will
come with this decision
it's the principle and they need to know
the principle I'm like no no but what
good will come of this decision like
sometimes the best decision to make is
nothing you know it's the decision of
indecision or the decision of no
decision
um uh but I I want to make sure that
good com good comes from my decisions
um yeah yeah
like like you know and and again so if
we let feed giving somebody feedback
right
like sometimes I want to give people
feedback because I really genuinely care
about them and I want them to grow and I
you know that we've all interacted with
people who would I'll give you a real
life example early early in my career
and I was just starting to start with
why there was no book no Ted Talk nobody
knew anything about me or any of my work
anything like that and I was I was
giving a presentation to a big
Conference of entrepreneurs business
people
a thousand people or something it was a
big deal for me it was it's very
exciting I got done giving the start
with why speech and the very first
comment a guy raises his hand and he
says have you ever led a billion dollar
company
I said no
he said have you ever let a
significant size team
I said no
he goes well I think you're naive
I think that nothing that you've talked
about today will is based in reality and
I don't think your work
um is is realistic in the real world
and I said
so don't do it
next question please
right and the point is like what good
will come of me defending my ideas and
preaching to him he's not open to an
alternative way of thinking and I'm cool
with that
my job is not to fight with you and be
the entertainment for the room for the
day you know
like right they're like no good no good
will come from me picking this fight you
know taking the bait because that's what
I said at the start about the quitting
framework yeah which is at some point
you go the rewards on offer here are not
worth but I I think I think I think the
you know
I think quitting is a is a
I think quitting is um an
underappreciated topic you know I I
think that like you must never quit you
know it's like you have to have grit I'm
like that's really bad advice but at the
same time you know you should you know
you just quit quitting easily there's
also bad advice and so the question and
I grapple with the same thing is you're
like well when do you quit and when do
you not quit I I literally wrote a
framework for this to help me understand
in hindsight why why I quit sometimes
and why I don't and it's it kind of goes
how I said where are you thinking about
quitting there's kind of a flowchart
where on the left hand side you're
thinking about quitting because it's
hard okay so is the is the hardship
worth the worth the effort and that's
these are all broad subjective things
but you have to separate something being
hard from something in my words from
being from sucking sucking is like that
misery it's that like kind of the toxic
miserableness that I experienced in my
companies or that people experience at
work or they experience in a
relationship hardship is like the physic
the physical hardship it's not you know
what I mean and that's the distinction
that I'm trying to make that's that's I
I have an example that I think might
make tangible okay what you're trying to
say which is
Leaders Eat Last was
the most difficult thing I've ever
written the most difficult thing I've
ever done writing that book was
excruciating and impossible and the
reason was it was like a Pandora's Box
which every single chapter could have
been a book unto itself and there was so
much like start with why I was something
like 68 000 words something like that
um and when I sat down to write leaders
At Last I wrote 150 000 words and I
thought I was just getting started like
it just was never ending
and I couldn't organize the information
and I couldn't understand when I got
started like why had none of the social
scientists that I was interviewing how
come none of them has ever taken the
biology of human decision making
oxytocin and serotonin how come none of
them never taken these chemicals and
overlaid them in a corporate culture and
written about it it's because it was
absolutely impossible to organize
and I couldn't figure it out
and I I the stress was extraordinary I
lost two relationships writing that book
because I was not in my best mind I was
it was awful and so at some point I quit
and I realized it beat me it won I can't
do it and I remember I
uh went for a walk I was living in New
York City and I and the reason it was
about eight o'clock nine o'clock at
night and I went for a walk and I was
walking to plan my exit I was I went to
plan the checklist of quitting so I
would have to call the publisher and say
I can't do it which is technically a
breach of contract which means I'd have
to give my Advance back okay that's
gonna suck but okay I'd have to tell all
the people who supported me and were
friends that I can't do it and I'd be
humiliated but I'll get Everett and so
will they I'd have to tell the people
who were big fans of my first book that
second book that I told you was coming
it's not coming they'll be disappointed
I'll be humiliated they'll get over it
I'll get over it like literally going
through the emotional and practical
checklist of quitting
going through all the steps that I had
to do
and for some reason I don't know why I
called a friend of mine who at the time
was in the Air Force Special Forces and
I called him up and I don't even think I
said hello when he picked up the phone
he was active duty at the time and I
said what do you do when you can't
complete the mission
and as is his nature he started telling
me a story
he said um
he used to be a helicopter pilot he said
they were assigned to go on this mission
in Afghanistan and all the intelligence
said that it was a suicide mission and
not a suicide mission like kill Hitler
and you're going to die it was like
you're all going to die and the mission
will fail like there's it's just a
worthless loss of life right and as they
were preparing for this Mission they all
knew that that's what the intelligence
was that this was this was literally a
pointless mission
and they were prepping their helicopter
and his wingman turned him they got
wives they've got kids
his wingman tournament says what do we
what do we do like do we refuse to go
like what do we do
and my friend said to him no this is
what we signed up for we go
obviously cooler heads prevailed and the
mission was scrapped
before they left
and then he tells me the story and then
he says to me
is this book more or less powerful than
the first book you wrote and I said it's
having a greater impact on my life just
in the research than the first book he
goes okay I'll tell you a funny story he
says before I met you I was completely
disillusioned with the military I didn't
know what kind of leader I could be and
I read this kooky little book that
somebody gave me called start with Y and
it completely re-inspired me and I can
tell you the reason I'm still here is
loving my job is because of that book
and if you're telling me that this thing
that you're working on is more powerful
than the first book then
you have to write this book he says this
is what you signed up for you have no
choice now he didn't mean this is what
you signed up for you have no choice
what he meant was this is what you
signed up for you have no choice and I
will be there with you every step of the
way just like that was the underlying
message to his wingman I'm going to go
with you we're gonna die together
I literally turned around went back to
my apartment and finished writing that
book obviously not that night
and the the pain was excruciating but I
realized that the stakes were worth it
and that's what you mean by hardship
versus sucking yeah like it was
unbelievably hard but it didn't suck
yeah and it did it did have health
consequences and it you know it made me
stressed out of my mind you know
sleeping became difficult and there was
a moment where you weren't sure whether
it was hard and worth it it was I I
there was a point where I I couldn't
understand if it was if it sucked or it
was hard and this is why I think to go
back and I sort of pushed you a little
bit before which is
I'm not always sure that we by ourselves
can distinguish because hardship and
sucking often feel the same sleepless
nights stressed out of my mind I'm
short-tempered I'm losing relationships
my friends [__] hate me you know and
I think it sometimes takes
calling one of those friends who you
know loves you and asking them why am I
doing this and I love the question that
I asked him how do you know
you know how do you know when when to
quit the mission
and
um
and his answer was basically if it's
worth it to other people
and you signed up for a life of service
you have no choice but but the most
important thing was I felt alone prior
to that and I never felt alone after so
it still was awful except I felt
oh I felt hard and supported versus hard
and alone
and so I think
not quitting
the decision to not quit the check is
Will somebody support me and if other
people think it's not worth it then
they're not going to support me
especially if it's a selfish Pursuit
right I'm going to make a million
dollars nobody gives a [__] about you
and your financial Ambitions nobody's
gonna sweat with you for that because
that's just for your benefit and well
the funny thing is I didn't hate every
second because there were epiphanies
that were magical
but there were two years of my life that
were awful and it was a hundred percent
worth it and that's a situation where
you don't quit that's a situation where
you don't quit I told you about my
discipline equation didn't I I don't
remember it remind me we think we talked
about on stage but I was trying to
figure out why some areas of my life I
have high discipline in and I was so the
discipline equation that I came up with
was at the start of the equation you
have the why oh yes the reason for doing
it so you just gave a list of y's there
plus the psychological enjoyment you get
from the pursuit itself yeah minus the
psychological disengagement or
unenjoyment that you get from the
pursuit yeah and trying to make sure and
even in the case of writing that book
you said like it was it was incredibly
unengaging and unenjoyable so that part
of the equation rose up the enjoyment
part Rose down but the bit that you
managed to get back up again was the why
part of the equation yeah so you go like
if you said like why plus enjoyment plus
I know friction yeah
um I constantly think about ways in
areas of my life that I can remind
myself of why I'm doing this thing I can
make the pursuit of the thing as enjoy
in frictionless as possible and I can
limit the discomfort and friction of the
pursuit of the thing so djang is a good
example
really really love music one to DJ
I'm clear on that I have to remind
myself by by putting the Deep my DJing
decks as the wallpaper on my on my
iPhone the process of actually
practicing and doing DJing is therapy is
therapeutic playing the music I love so
it's a really enjoyable Pursuit now the
friction is time and setting up the DJ
equipment and the nerves you get when
you walk out on stage that's all
friction how do I limit and that's where
I think I've come to learn in my life
what the things I'm disciplined on are
when the why and the pursuit are there
and the friction is low the annoying
thing about talking to you
is I could talk to you forever yeah
and
there's a point at which I think we have
to pull the rip cord yeah this might be
that time I'm gonna back go back to what
I said before I think you you are
you are representative of
of CEO 2.0
for a modern era
and I tell you this not to blow smoke up
your ass
I tell you this because I think the
stakes are high
and I think you're Reinventing
what leading a company looks like that
flies in the face of what too many
leaders and Future Leaders have been
told or are being told
and you lead by example and you are you
are an example of what leadership should
look like and
if you get distracted by temptation
um
don't [__] it up
because the stakes are high
it's the future of business and all the
people who work in those businesses and
there's this rise of populism and this
rise of
anti-uh authority and anti-leadership in
in government or in business and people
are cynical and rightfully so
and I think that leaders like you or the
antidote I honestly believe it I think
if
if you get this wrong
I think that the social ripples are
significant you and I both meet a lot of
people not a lot of them
lead like you do I'm a preacher like I
talk about ideas I share ideas I write
about ideas
I'm a proselytizer I'm a preacher like
I'm I'm preaching
what what what things could look like
and offering some tools about how to get
there
but you you're doing the things
and you know the fact that you would say
to me that
one of my books had such a profound
impact that you changed the way you led
your business is the reason why you have
to keep doing it because you're a
tangible representation of a
philosophical idea that I talk about
I really appreciate that I find it
really difficult to take compliments
just say thank you say thank you
but I know I really appreciate that and
um
yeah I really appreciate that and I
appreciate all the wonderful things
you've done for me I mean the first time
you came on the podcast I
there's a part of me that still freaks
out about the fact that you you even
said yes to coming on no I'm being
honest of course because you're someone
that I've been reading about and you
know your books have helped me in such a
profound way that uh to have those
initial conversations in our friendship
with you is something I hold and I
cherish greatly yeah and everything
you've said about the responsibility
part
I really hope that I can continue to be
honest with myself yeah that's what
that's the thing I hope I can do and I
hope I can go further in that direction
because there's a lot of people
listening now so I hope that
um I can continue to be honest and open
and in doing so we create these
environments where
um it brings value to people so that's
my objective that's the responsibility
that I spoke about with Rebecca in the
things that keep me up at night and all
of those things is that sense of like I
have a chance to do some good stuff
um so I'm gonna do my best to continue
this is what you signed up for you have
no choice and I will be with you every
step of the way thank you